now in 2009 when the tea party took off
the issue that had so many americans
energized was the opposition to
obamacare
in 2021 the issue is education the one
good thing about the awful terrible
pandemic is that parents had the time to
burrow into their children's schooling
and many were horrified about what they
saw
it turns out that a new so-called
anti-racism and gender equity focus
wasn't so popular after all
poison this will tear this country apart
if it becomes a part of our fabric
critical race theory which is pretty
much going to be teaching kids how to
hate each other how to dislike each
other just because i do not want
critical race theory taught to my
children in school
does not mean that i am a racist dammit
well apparently school boards across
america thought they could radically
revamp course offerings from american
history to literature
and no one would notice
but they were badly mistaken
now parents and citizens alike see how
activists promoting a deeply
anti-american agenda have wormed their
way into almost every facet of the
educational experience
well parents should be upset about this
and their concerns are not political
they're practical
parents are saying
hey my kid's not reading and writing at
grade level but somehow they have time
to hold assemblies on diversity equity
inclusion and police brutality or
they're saying in school they put more
focus on george floyd than george
washington
parents should be demanding answers
because schools have become a minefield
for democrats of course the biden
administration just reflexively took the
side of school boards against the
parents
now after the national school board
association pleaded for relief
claiming its members were under siege
the department of justice snapped into
action i've never seen anything like it
in their own memo they warned of a
disturbing spike in harassment
intimidation and threats of violence
against school administrators and
promised to take action if necessary
it sent a chilling message to moms and
dads pretty much anyone interested from
coast to coast
beware joining a movement that we
essentially link to domestic terror
when a firestorm then erupted the
national school board association pulled
back they saw they had created a bit of
a ruckus so they apologized for the
descriptions of parents as violent
harassing menaces
but when pressed today on why the doj
hasn't also rescinded its follow-on
letter attorney general merrick garland
just dug in
presumably you wrote the memo because of
the letter
the letter is disavowed now so you're
going to keep your memo going anyway
right is that what you're telling me
senator i have the letter from nsba that
you're referring to
it apologizes for language in the letter
but it con continues its concern
about the safety of school officials and
school staff
okay if the point wasn't to intimidate
parents it's all justifiable why did the
doj invoke a national security component
you're going to create a task force that
includes the national security division
what is the national security division
have to do with parents at school boards
this is not again about parents at
school boards it's about threats of
violence
again this begs the question why would
this suddenly be a new federal matter
any threats or violence are already
prosecutable under state law as well as
federal law in some cases
so why the need for a doj task force
how is it the department of justice was
able to move so rapidly
on a single letter from a special
interest group that has now repudiated
that letter said it regret sending the
letter and apologize to its members for
sending a letter the answer is when we
get reports of violence and threats of
violence we need to act very swiftly you
didn't investigate before you issued
your memorandum the incidences
cited in the letter did you
look i took the
a statement by the national association
when they said that they were facing
violence and threats of violence and
when i saw in the news media of reports
yeah but you didn't investigate the
incidents in the letter did you no
this is the first step this is an
assessment step it comes before
investigations
come on we all know what happened
presumably the white house let it be
known that they needed this whole school
controversy to quiet down and for
parents to pipe down
dangling the possibility of fbi action
against parents just attending school
board meetings would be one way to get
that done or so they thought
this was all coordinated and it blew up
spectacularly
are you aware of conversations between
your department of justice officials and
white house officials and the members of
the school board association all
cooperating together as i said i am sure
there were conversations with the white
house i have no idea whether there were
conversations with the school board
association there's nothing wrong with
there being such conversations there's
nothing that i knew about this
organization to suggest that it is
anyway partisan
all those conservatives on school boards
and associations for school boards
of course it's not partisan none of this
is partisan it's all just a coincidence
that school boards are overwhelmingly
liberal
and what about this underlying evidence
is there really a growing national
threat posed against these school boards
committee chair teachers union apologist
dick durbin was reaching for anything
those who argue that school board
meetings across america are not more
dangerous and more violent than in the
past or ignoring reality i went on it
and just typed in this morning school
board violence
on
one of the search engines
page after page is coming up
24 years in the senate ladies and
gentlemen and he's just entering terms
into search engines and then proclaiming
it as so
another argument for term limits
this is all too much
and if glenn younkin wins the virginia
gubernatorial race
it will be because he focused so much on
the travesty unfolding on the education
issue in loudoun county
rapes and school bathrooms and
classrooms a cover-up and the harassment
of parents
who dared to ask questions even the
family of the victim
meanwhile democrat candidate terry
mcauliffe is flailing
i am sick of them talking about these
issues of critical race theory we do not
teach critical race theory here in
virginia it has never been taught it is
a racist dog whistle this is all
generated by glenn yonko this is what
ms-13 the republicans used on governor
north from four years ago when he was
run it they try to find a divisive
tactic
that's pathetic mcauliffe is too bought
off by the teachers unions to see
that this goes way beyond glenn yonkin
this is about parents discovering many
cases for the first time
the truth about a growing socialist
monopoly in education
the angle warned you about this over a
year ago
black lives matter zealots now have
outsized influence in school districts
like fairfax county and their goal is to
turn your kids into hardcore activists
by remaking education from top to bottom
i watch hours of these school board
meetings and it's horrifying what we're
seeing it's a big business critical race
theory anti-racism pedagogy cultural
marxism implicit bias training
decolonizing syllabi
and this extremism is like a cult
and now that many of us are on to them
progressive school boards and districts
across america are freaking out
do they change the radical course or do
they just try to discourage parental
involvement on all these hot button
issues
the mankato minnesota school board chose
the latter
this is a business meeting of the school
board
it is not a meeting that belongs to the
public
each speaker is asked to state his or
her name and address for the record
failure to do so will result in an
individual not being allowed to speak
open forum participants are prohibited
from calling out or addressing any
individual school board
or school district staff member
do you understand what she said this is
not a public matter
so if a parent's concern is not on
her agenda
i guess the controversy you're concerned
didn't happen it doesn't matter it's
like magic it just goes away how
convenient
sounds like there is another school
board that needs to be replaced
tax paying parents fund the public
schools and rightly deserve answers and
accountability
any politician i mean any politician who
stands in the way of this legitimate
exercise of parental rights and any
bureaucrat who uses procedural gimmicks
to insulate himself from criticism
should be tossed from office as soon as
possible
this spells political defeat for
mcauliffe and countless democrats who
believe they're above reproach as long
as they're woke and that's the angle hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else